here we go guys all right show time guys  you ready  it says POTUS that's where it's coming  from  coach put me in I'm ready to play  you guys I know you're the underdog but  uh tell you what man you got some of the  best players in the world on your team  and you're representing this country and  I know you're going to play your hearts  out so let's go shock them all you keep  trusting to one another play as hard as  you can and you know for you and your  families your teammates and the whole  country's rooting for you I wish I was  there to see you I really do go get them  guys just play your hearts out we got  this I know you will I know you will  all right that was nice huh  [Applause]